bon alors un jour je suis mort j'avais
25 ans c'est à paris faisait un temps
absolument magnifique et du monde
partout il y avait des ponts les amants
à la bourre mais moi je suis mort
j'avais une anomalie cardiaque
congénitale de naissance très grave
qu'on a découvert sur le tard et il a
fallu qu'on l'opère de toute urgence
donc ils ont arrêté mon coeur ce
matin-là 9h par hypothermie
certains jours sans déconner la vie
tient à pas grand chose et tient à un
fil électrique celui là donc ils ont
ouvert ils ont réparé ça a duré 12
heures 12 heures et puis après il a
fallu renaître après il a fallu renaître
je faisais 35 kilos et je me suis battu
comme un forçat pour être là aujourd'hui
en pleine forme avec vous voilà et je me
suis bien battu d'ailleurs en bas marié
deux enfants une baraque bagnols une
telle est épanoui dans un métier de la
mort qui tue les noms mais normale comme
tout le monde j'ai plus besoin de
m'encombrer de mon coeur voilà je vous
remercie et à bientôt
non en fait
en fait pas tout c'est pas tout à fait
fini ça aurait été le cas s'il n'y avait
pas eu l'autisme lotissement l'autisme
bon alors la première fois qu'on a parlé
d' autisme pour mon fils j'ai tout
d'abord pensé à un ascenseur est pas ce
que je faisais pas vous mais moi je me
fais souvent chez dans les ascenseurs et
du coup je regarde toujours là je fixe
la petite plaque signalétique avec la
marque d'ascenseur dessus alors je
connais toutes les marques d'ascenseur
parker vachement intéressant et donc la
première fois qu'on m'a parlé d' autisme
pour mon fils j'ai pensé aux tice alors
c'était évidemment en ces premiers jours
d'école il ya sept ans alors il est pas
normal il n'était pas comme les autres
trois jours d'école il jouait dans son
coin et ses talents surtout le pire
il rentrait pas dans les apprentissages
et alors ça les apprentissages c'est un
truc à l'école si vous rentrez pas
dedans vous avez une maladie mentale
c'est pas les maladies mentales qui
manquent vous prenez le dictionnaire des
des maladies mentales aux états unis 1
vous pensiez tous en forme eh ben non
raté vous avez tous besoin d'être soigné
bon donc évidemment comme tout le monde
je me suis précipité sur internet pour
savoir ce que c'était que ce machin là
autisme
oh le con oh le con ne jamais faire ça
je suis passé en trois clics si vous
voulez deux ascenseurs à une espèce de
concept global totalement imbitable 1 ou
en plus de ça tout est fait pour qu'on
ait peur globalement donc je savais
qu'il fallait pas aller sur internet
quand on a des problèmes à régler comme
ça ça m'est arrivé avec ma voiture
j'avais un problème tu peux v1 prennent
de boîte de vitesses et j'étais sur
internet je me suis retrouvé avec un
cancer du bras droit
j'étais bien avancé donc en fait
globalement l'autisme c'est à peu près
la consécration absolue mais merveilleux
progrès qu'internet a apporté au domaine
de la santé
c'est à dire que avant internet chaque
question n'avait pas forcément sa
réponse bon bah depuis internet chaque
réponse n'a pas forcément sa question
voilà alors du coup moi en sept ans un
ébat j'ai toujours rien compris
alors il ya une quantité d'informations
sur l'autisme absolument hallucinante
hallucinante mais en fait on vous
explique jamais concrètement ce que
c'est l'autisme on vous explique très
bien comment sortir de l'autisme mais
par contre on ne sait pas bien ce que
c'est l'autisme et d'ailleurs je
constate souvent que on dit tout le
temps ce que les autistes ne sont pas
mais jamais ce qu'ils sont donc alors
parce qu'il faut il faut quand même
savoir une chose c'est que vous pensez
quand on pense autisme vous penser
globalement tous à peu près comme tout
le monde
rain man un bon eh ben c'est pas faux
mais c'est pas vrai non plus c'est pas
vrai non plus parce que en fait
l'autisme aujourd'hui c'est un spectre
voyez je vous avais dit que ça faisait
peur c'est un spectre
ou un spectre qui va de effectivement un
trouble neurologique très impressionnant
jusqu'à un trouble du comportement qui
serait caractérisé par des stéréotypes y
ait ou une altération social réciproque
et encore et c'est même pas sûr parce
que les critères change tous les deux
ans si bien que tout le monde s'engueule
alors vas-y pour tir trouvait d'ailleurs
moi c'est bien simple je reviens à ma
première idée mon fils y les ascenseurs
voilà ils souffrent eux mêmes du
syndrome de l'ascenseur non spécifié et
comme ce mot là et ben l'acronyme
s'affaissant sns est pas mon fils quand
on me demande fléchit les sens oui mais
laisse en quoi est il est sans tout
court et en maladie mentale comment ce
petit à la maison non mais franchement
ça fait des années que la recherche
travaille à isoler le gène de l'autisme
certains jours je me dis qu'elle ferait
bien de se concentrer sur celui de la
connerie ça rendrait service à beaucoup
plus de monde
bon alors vous devez vous demander
pourquoi je suis là quand même assez
détendu en train de vous parler d'un
sujet qui est grave parce que c'est vrai
que l'autisme ces grades et je peux
quand même vous en témoigner en termes
de galère on est bien servi
monsieur termine pas son assiette ouais
c'est à dire que là j'hésite entre le
sel et le sucre parce que c'est un peu
amer
voilà donc en fait je me suis simplement
souvenu de trois choses que j'avais
envie de partager avec vous et qui sont
d'ailleurs trois choses que qui nous
rassemble avec d'autres familles
nous sommes touchés par l'autisme et
c'est une association pour la montée
ensemble qui s'appelle la main à
l'oreille alors je vais vous dire c'est
trois choses et puis à la fin si vous
êtes sympas je vous le dire un petit
secret alors la première chose je suis
très embêté parce qu'en général on ne
croit pas et je vais encore passer pour
un mytho tant pis c'est que je me suis
rendu compte qu'on était encore des
êtres humains
je sais c'est pas évident à croire hein
mais bon l'avocat un jour je suis tombé
sur une plaidoirie la plaidoirie de
maître dupond-moretti qui commençait de
cette façon là il disait tout ce que m'a
appris mon métier d'avocat c'est que les
êtres sont tous d'une extrême fragilité
moi ça m'a fait du bien en temps ça ça
m'a fait du bien parce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans une société où la
performance et dieu il ya performance
industrielle performances commerciales
performances professionnelles
performances scolaires
ouais ouais il ya performances sexuelles
aussi ça marche et c'est à ce point vrai
que je me suis rendu compte que dès
qu'un être humain ne fonctionne pas à
plein régime de ses capacités il est
diagnostiqué d'une maladie mentale
alors bon il ya autisme mais il ya aussi
tout ce qui commence par dix ans les
disorders dit s'orthographie j'ai
entendu dyscalculie a pas longtemps mais
est ce que les fragilités humaines sont
des maladies mentales en fait est ce
qu'on devrait guérir d'être des êtres
humains
bon heureusement la france a quand même
un peu de retard dans ce domaine là et
on ne considère pas encore l'homme comme
une machine comme les autres et puis
c'est vrai que certains jours quand même
les américains avec leur technologie
station de l'être humain
ils me font parfois marais d'ailleurs je
me marre un phare pour la deuxième chose
que je me suis rappelé c'est que un jour
j'ai lu le petit prince
voilà et je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais au début du petit prince
on nous explique que le petit prince
vient de l'astéroïde b612 et en c'est
très important parce que si et si c'est
un aussi important pardon c'est à cause
des grandes personnes ce que les grandes
personnes ont besoin de chiffres sinon
elles contraignent rien bon et c'est
vrai que dans nos sociétés aujourd'hui
du chiffre on en bouffe on en bouffe il
ya une échelle pour tous c'est à dire
qu'on comprend la santé d'un pays que à
son taux de chômage ou son taux de
croissance
par exemple on est intelligent que sur
un cui chiffres et on comprend un
phénomène que si on a le nombre de morts
voilà et puis à l'école sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais en fait on est plus
comme avant les enfants à s'épanouir à
grandir
on n'en ont compte en compte les
compétences acquises pas acquis voilà
donc d'ailleurs moi c'est bien simple
pour vivre avec mon époque quand on me
demande si je vais bien je réponds la
réponse et 42
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des geeks un
pardon donc moi mon fils en fait quand
il a su lire il s'est écrié maman je
sais lire je vole si bien que maintenant
d'ailleurs depuis il passe beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à lire et quand on
l'interrompt dans une lecture
il nous y allons maintenant vous pas
gaspiller les livres bon le problème
c'est qu'il ait jamais rentrer dans ce
jeu d évaluation quand on en cherche à
quelques à mesurer sa performance de
lecture ici refuse moralité il assure
ses carnets scolaires ne sait pas lire
voilà alors mon petit bonhomme lui il
vient pas comme le petit prince de
l'astéroïde b612 il vient pas non plus
comme l'allumeur de réverbères de
l'astéroïde 3b 329 nom lui vient d'une
enfant ou plutôt il l'est dans une une
bonne cellule excellent b 617 d'un
classeur de statistiques la case des à
part voilà mais ceci dit c'est un peu
dommage parce que j'ai quand même
remarqué que plus une société chiffres
sa performance et puis il ya des
problèmes et puis il ya des problèmes
vous prenez la corée du sud par exemple
corée du sud
extraordinaire pays c'est le meilleur
pays au monde en termes de résultats
scolaires meilleur pays au monde selon
le cdh est bon ce qu'on sait moins c'est
que selon l' ocde
c'est aussi le pays qui a le plus grand
nombre de suicides chez les jeunes mais
ça va encore plus loin parce que en
france on considère que un enfant sur
110 ou 150 ça dépend des études naître
est autiste
bon bah en corée du sud c'est un sur 38
voilà donc ceci démontre que ce qui est
statistiquement justes et parfois quand
même humainement faux et que si les
grandes personnes font des contres
parfaits se trompe souvent de calcul la
dernière chose m'est venue en regardant
un documentaire sur l'autisme un jour
alors on voyait des gens dans le
documentaire faut le sortir de son monde
et tout va sortir ton vous sortir de son
monde et tout bon
moi j'ai pas été d'accord avec les gens
je bourgines sale manie c'est pas très à
la mode mais je fais confiance à mon
fils et je me suis dit que s'il était
dans son monde c'est peut-être parce
qu'il était bien dans son monde alors je
me suis dit que le mieux c'était
peut-être que moi j'allais faire un
petit tour dans son monde voilà alors je
ne savais pas très bien comment m'y
prendre
et puis un jour très impassible il m'a
regardé comme ça m a dit tu sais papa ça
se visite une vie alors j'ai réalisé que
j'étais quand même un bon gros touristes
dans la mienne déjà du coup je me suis
dit qu'elle ait fait un tour dans la
sienne 16 c'était possible quoi débat
vous savez qu'il est pas mal ce on sait
qu'il est même magnifique il est
extraordinaire j'ai découvert par
exemple que les adultes stressé et qui
se fâchent sont faits en plastique et
qui sont fabriqués en chine
ouais j'ai j'ai découvert qu'on pouvait
inventer une écriture des toiles et puis
il m'a appris que un jour quand j'avais
25 ans j'avais eu des étincelles dans le
coeur alors au départ il faut apprendre
sur langage quand même hein parce que
c'est un langage un peu différent et par
exemple il faut comprendre que le sens
figuré n'existe pas d'accord donc
physiquement on se donne pas la main
pour traverser une rue parce que si on
se donne la main après on en a plus quoi
bah ouais ensuite on peut être frappé
par la beauté d'un paysage ça fait pas
mal ça fait pas mal et puis ça s'arrête
se donnait des claques quand on veut se
donner du mal
voilà et puis c'est peut-être aussi
d'ailleurs parce que c'est mal de volée
qu'on met les oiseaux en cage
voilà donc ouais mon fils je rends
visite dans son monde et j'aime bien y
aller puis vient de temps en temps dans
le lien maintenant et je voudrais qu un
jour ici sens bien mais je veux pas
qu'il en oublie son monde parce que les
autistes ont des choses à nous dire à
nous nous les normaux totalement obsédée
par notre normalité quoi par exemple
l'été dernier il montait tous les soirs
sur la table du jardin là où on dit non
et ne remonte pas sur les tables c'est
mal tout chat un mâle se passe pour sam
à chambon de stars
alors tous les soirs à la même heure il
remontait sur sa table donc ça servait à
rien si bien que j'ai fini par en avoir
marre de m'énerver et puis subitement je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai j'ai repensé aux
serres qui peut être disparu vous savez
le passage où ils montent tous sur les
tables en disant au capitaine mon
capitaine pour regarder la vie sous un
angle différent
alors je suis monté avec lui et puis
j'ai découvert que au dessus du toit de
la maison il y avait une lune absolument
magnifique magnifique on voyait pas de
quand on était par terre et puis il m'a
dit très doucement n'avait pas pas elle
est encore plus belle hier soir en fait
depuis une semaine tous les soirs ils
allaient voir la lune 1 alors moi du
coup bah maintenant je fais comme lui je
fais comme il c'est à dire que je monte
sur les tables pour regarder la vie d'un
angle différent et pour voir comment ses
plus gros quand on est un peu plus haut
sous un autre regard
voilà alors je vais vous dire mon secret
comme vous avez été vachement sympa je
vous donnais mon secret mon secret c'est
que j'ai cavaler après la normalité
pendant des années pensant que c'était
ça qui me soigne qui me soignerai mon
coeur et bien en fait j'ai découvert en
travaillant ce tedx que c'est peut-être
et même sûrement l'autisme qui finirait
de réparer mon coeur bonne soirée